hiatus edition of pft live and pft
pm working our way closer and closer to
the start of training camp and you never
know where the lightning bolt is going
to come from that news that was
unexpected but based on history we
come to expect it expect the unexpected
when it comes to injuries you never know
who it's going to be but you always know
it's going to be someone now usually it
happens during camp or the preseason
but in this last sliver of time where
players are
trying to get themselves in as you'll
hear time and again the best shape of
their lives
accidents can happen cam acres the rams
running back done for the year
with a torn achilles tent and that is a
huge blow to
him and to the rams offense because he
had grown
into a guy who was ready to become the
centerpiece of the running game last
year it felt like the rams
wanted to mimic what the 49ers have been
doing with multiple tailbacks
in and out of the lineup different plays
different
guys different drives different featured
backs caremakers emerged over the course
of the season as the guy who was ready
to become
basically their next todd gurley and
that's how it was looking going into
this season now
acres abruptly gone they can look for
some alternatives on the roster they
could try to sign a veteran i know todd
gurley's name immediately trending on
twitter
i don't think the rams are going to be
bringing him back the rams know that
his knee limits his ability to be the
tailback that they need him
to be there are some veterans out there
like adrian peterson and frank gore they
could trade for someone they could wait
for guys to be cut
however it goes this is a major blow for
a rams offense that was going to rely
very very heavily on acres who was ready
to explode in year two
as a potential star player in the
national football league they still have
matthew stafford they still have a great
core of past
catchers now they're going to have to
deal with the sudden and unexpected loss
of cam acres for all of the 2021 season
just the first of what hopefully won't
be many
but inevitably more injuries that will
happen
over the course of the next several
weeks and then once the games start
we know every week there will be someone
or more than someone who is out for the
year and i think it's easier to process
as a fan when it happens within the
context of a game that counts toward the
final standings
it's harder to deal with it when it
happens in practice or in the pre-season
and it's very hard for fans to process
it when
it occurs before training camp even
begins but all the best cam acres as he
recovers from that torn achilles
and we'll see what the rams do moving
forward
there were some comments earlier on
tuesday from seahawks receiver tyler
locke that i just want to mention
briefly
he said that he expects russell wilson
to be on the seahawks for the
foreseeable future now i don't know what
that means because
really most football players don't
foresee much of a future beyond
the coming season because every season
is kind of its own entity now
in the national football league the
teams change so much there's never going
to be
another 2021 seahawks 2022
guys will be gone new guys will come
changes will be made
quite possibly to coaching staff and and
and it's a new thing
when the next season rolls around so
foreseeable future to me as far as the
nfl is concerned
foreseeable future is a year and so in
that respect i agree with tyler lockett
because i expect
russell wilson to be the quarterback of
the seahawks for all of the 2021 season
after the season what happens i believe
is going to depend in large part on how
this season goes
if it goes very well for the seahawks if
they get back to the nfc championship
for the first time since
2014 and yes it's been that long since
they've been
into the final four for the nfl then
maybe russell wilson signs up for
another year if they
fail again to get beyond the wild card
round or beyond the divisional round
we may hear some of the same things we
heard directly from wilson
in february and the things that came
from his agent about the teams that he
would accept to trade to
you know tyler lockett tries to downplay
all of this as the media looking for
things to talk about during the slow
time first of all it's not slow in
february and march there's plenty of
other stuff happening
and when a guy's agent a franchise
quarterbacks agent one of the best
quarterbacks in the game one of the best
quarterbacks to ever play the game
comes out and says well my client
doesn't want to be traded but if he were
to be traded here are the four teams
he'd accept the trade to
that's never happened before that's news
that's not the media making something
out of nothing
that's the media doing its job when one
of the newsmakers
makes something whether it was wilson in
his comments to dan patrick
or agent mark rogers and his comments to
adam schefter
whatever the case it's newsworthy so
don't blame us that it became a story it
became a story because wilson wanted it
to be a story
and for now the hatchet has been buried
but that hatchet will be unburied
if the seahawks struggle in 2021
or at least if they struggle to achieve
the kind of success
that will help further cement russell
wilson's legacy this is year 10 for him
he's got one super bowl win two super
bowl appearances and if he's not going
to get more of them with the seahawks he
is going to look
for another team where he can get that
kind of
achievement on his resume aaron rodgers
won super bowl appearance won super bowl
victory in his tenure that came way back
in 2010
the questions still linger about what
he's going to do now
here is a story that isn't about rogers
as much as it's about
maybe some of the behind the scenes
maneuvering from a pr
standpoint the story from tuesday
morning from adam schefter that
rogers turned down during the off-season
a contract offer that would have made
him the highest-paid player in the nfl
first of all that's not new and it's not
uncommon
for reporters to dust off old news and
maybe
add some little twist to it to to
justify making it a headline
but if adam schafter's being honest with
himself and with the audience he would
admit
that this is months old this has been
out there
that during the conversations that
occurred during the quiet time
in the off-season before rogers made it
known
that he wanted out the packers had
indeed offered him a contract that would
have made him
the highest paid player in football but
there continues to be a major gap when
it comes to the information that's been
reported
when you don't know the structure of the
deal it doesn't matter what the deal is
worth
you put a couple of non-guaranteed years
on the back end that bump the average
salary up over 45 million per year
hey he's the highest paid player in
football well yeah but
does it affect the fundamental problem
that motivated
all of this effort by rogers and this
goes back to january
and this is what we've said consistently
rogers no longer wants to be
one year at a time employed by the
packers he wants
security he wants to know he'll be there
two or three years
so he doesn't have to worry about being
supplanted by jordan love
if you give him a contract that has a
bunch of non-guaranteed money that makes
him
more highly paid than patrick holmes but
there's no guarantee he's going to be
there to make that money who cares
so the structure is the key a contract
that
forces the packers to keep aaron rodgers
for 2020
1 20 22 and maybe 2023 that's what he
wants that's what
let me be more accurate that's what he
wanted
it may be that the ship has sailed and
if they would show up now and say
okay aaron we'll give you what you
wanted back in january or february it
could be that erin where i just will say
hey
look you had your chance to do what you
needed to do
then you jerked me around you forced me
to play this game i didn't want to play
this game i just wanted to have a deal
that made me know i was going to be
here that i was the guy that you're as
committed to me as i am to you
you didn't do it you decided to go the
hard way
and now i'm i'm going the even harder
way and i'm going to continue to persist
in my desire
to be traded and i still think and i i
said this yesterday
where did i say it i think i said it on
dan patrick's show and some people have
misinterpreted what i
said i'm not reporting that rogers is
going to show up and that he's going to
get traded before week one
i just could envision roger's showing up
the packers specifically ceo mark murphy
not being happy with that outcome i
think murphy would prefer that roger's
not show then rogers becomes the villain
in all of this and the packers
if roger sits out the whole year they
they can make more than 30 million
dollars
back from rogers between salary that
won't be paid
signing bonus that can be recovered
roster bonus that won't be paid
fines if they collect them they're
looking at more than 30 million if he
chooses to boycott the whole year
if he shows up it could be that the
packers finally soften
in their stance that they're not going
to trade him
this whole we're not going to trade you
may be aimed at goading him into not
showing up
if he shows up they may say you know
we're better off moving on do we
really want this awkward final season
with aaron rodgers
where we constantly have to worry about
what kind of verbal shots he's going to
take while standing in front of his
locker i don't know that the packers
are going to want that if it comes to it
and that's why i think showing up
could be the key to rogers ending up
in what most likely at this point would
be denver for the 2021 season i can't
rule out anything we've seen so many
crazy things happen
in the nfl over the years how can you
rule out any possible permutation
or outcome of this rogers drama but the
bottom line is this
today's report from schefter is not new
and that news continues to be incomplete
because we don't know the structure and
finally this gets back to my original
point
i think shefter's doing somebody from
the packers a favor here because
here we are six days away from the
shareholder meeting and i've pointed out
mark murphy is going to face a hostile
crowd the packers want it to be known
that they've done everything in their
power to get rogers to stay
and the fact that rogers is still upset
doesn't reflect unreasonableness
on their part it reflects
unreasonableness
on his part
all right tony busby the lawyer who is
representing the 22 individuals who are
suing
deshaun watts and he had an interesting
post on instagram on monday now busby
remember back in march very vocal
posting all the time
comments observations developments
inflammatory things about desean watson
and the allegations that have been made
against him regarding
conduct during massage therapy sessions
well busby had been quiet
far more often than not since then it
continues to raise the possibility of a
settlement before training camp
busby had a message yesterday that i
think makes it much more difficult to
expect that these cases will be resolved
before the texans report to camp next
week
busby on his honeymoon with a gratuitous
shot at watson explaining that busby
went to a spa and got a massage and
then he deviated to discuss how he acted
properly and didn't do any of the
bizarre things that watson is accused of
doing
and it really felt unnecessary to me
and i think it does underscore that
right now there's a level of acrimony
that suggests these cases are indeed
going to go forward and the lingering
question continues to be
will the league put deshaun watson on
the commissioner exempt list he has not
been charged with a crime
it's 22 lawsuits is that enough to
justify
telling watson you can't play this year
but you'll be paid
and forcing the texans to pay him to be
on the commissioner exempt list whatever
the outcome
i persist in my position that the nfl
needs to let watson and the texans know
now
so everyone can make good decisions
about watson's future for 2021 including
a team
that may be interested in trading for
watson in the event that he's not going
to be placed
on paid leave but would be playing under
the cloud of these accusations
a lot of buzz yesterday from the
comments made by hall of fame receiver
michael irvin regarding
the vaccine and his logic is very simple
we've made this point in the past
in a different sort of a way i've argued
that
players will routinely
take substances that help them be
available to play
without giving a second thought to the
short-term
or long-term consequences whether it's a
ped that could get them suspended
whether it's some sort of permissible
supplement that could have
long-term health complications i mean
think of all the years where players
took steroids
knowing that it had both short-term and
long-term health effects
but they wanted to be available to play
with the vaccine if you don't get it
you are at risk any given sunday
every given sunday and every other day
of the week of testing positive and not
being available
you're not going to be available to your
team you're not going to be there for
the pursuit
of victories culminating in a chase for
a championship it's that simple
and that's ervin's point the players who
are committed to winning
will get the shot because it's a very
basic linear thought process
okay not getting vaccinated means what i
get tested every day
if i'm ever positive on game day or the
day before i can't play
don't want that if i'm vaccinated i only
get tested every two weeks
and maybe there's a reduced chance i'm
ever going to get it i know that people
who have
gotten vaccinated have gotten covered
but still you avoid that possibility
you're going to get tested on game day
and get knocked out of the lineup just
like that
so irving's attitude and his approach to
this makes a lot of sense the teams that
are truly committed to doing what they
have to do to win
and they check all the boxes there's a
bunch of boxes to check if you want to
be a winning football team one of the
boxes is
get vaccinated it's that simple and even
with that mindset which is accurate
there are still plenty of players out
there and also as i've heard
plenty of coaches who are vehemently
opposed
to the vaccine and it really is odd to
think that
in a sport that is so dominated by type
a triple positive personalities that
just want to win win win win win this is
something that gets in the way of
winning this is something that makes the
process more difficult
this is something that creates a
competitive disadvantage for the teams
that don't have
enough players vaccinated and a
competitive advantage for those who do
it's amazing that that's not enough to
bust through that wall just shows you
how strongly held the belief is by those
who don't want to be vaccinated that
there's some
sinister plot or unreasonable health
effect or
nanobots floating around in your
bloodstream or whatever the case may be
and
at this point i don't think anything's
going to change anyone's mind
a couple of others real quick before we
wrap it up for today
actually moved faster than i thought i
was going to so i can slow down a little
bit here i want to
i want to take a minute or two to
address
the news that came out of the blue early
yesterday evening east coast time
that raiders president mark bedane
has resigned and it didn't come from him
it came from his boss former boss team
owner mark davis
and the circumstances the way that it
got out
it it it begs for more
information and investigation and it
could be that
part of whatever severance agreement was
reached prevents
the dane from saying anything about it
it's just
odd to me that on the brink
of allegiant stadium opening up to fans
and the dane who was chiefly responsible
for navigating these very murky and
treacherous waters
that resulted in a team that could not
get a new stadium in oakland
finding a deal in las vegas a great deal
in las vegas
a deal that could make the raiders the
most valuable franchise in all of sports
given that location
that the dane isn't even going to be
there for the first game
where it's a real game where it's full
and people can enjoy it and it's the
crowning achievement
of the effort that you put into it so it
just makes people think something else
is going on and we'll see we'll see
there's plenty of reporters out there
i am sure who are scouring for any and
all information about it
whether they cover the raiders whether
they just cover the nfl generally
whether their their angle is
investigating matters like this i'm not
saying that there's anything there i'm
just saying there's reason to
explore what the real story is because
the circumstances suggest that
that this is unusual that this is
something that that wasn't planned or
wasn't expected
all right let's answer a few questions
before we wrap this up today
gotta find the tweet scrolling scrolling
had it ready but to accidentally close
my phone wait here it is just a few
questions let's see if there's
there's any actual questions instead of
just some smart alec remarks
how difficult will it be for an
unvaccinated player to get through the
season that question comes from tom
marshall also known as at a red zone alk
one of our
most loyal listeners and followers for
years now
i i
don't think it will be inordinately
difficult for an unvaccinated player to
get through the season but as i already
mentioned
you get tested every single day if
you're not vaccinated if you are
vaccinated you get tested once every two
weeks
so unvaccinated player constant risk
that today is the day that
that he's going to be shut down so it's
going to be like last year for an
unvaccinated player and as the delta
variant spreads
and his people have kind of let their
guard down generally about the pandemic
and don't seem to be inclined to put
their guard back up
maybe the risk is greater this year
maybe people will be looser
maybe there will be less of a degree of
safety that we saw last year and maybe
of the unvaccinated players there will
be a higher percentage
who test positive but the best way to
make yourself available
in as many games as possible this year
clearly and undoubtedly is to get
vaccinated but as i said
nothing is going to change the minds of
those who are determined at this point
to not get the jab
donegan mj who gets the playoff buys and
do they make it to
the super bowl remember there's now only
one buy per conference which
means one fewer game that the one seat
in each conference has to play i think
in the nfc
the tampa bay buccaneers have everything
pointing in their favor to be the number
one seed and i understand that
a certain amount of complacency can set
in for a super bowl champion but not
with tom brady
who is obsessed now with getting number
eight now that he has seven it's on to
eight once he gets eight it's on to nine
and when you look at the quality of the
rest of the teams in the nfc
i don't know who can challenge them hey
the saints may still be pretty good
after all the saints won the division
last year
maybe we're overlooking the saints maybe
they'll win the division again and the
buccaneers have to do it the hard way
like they did in 2020.
the rams thought they were going to be
pretty good now this cam akers thing
changes that outlook and even so they're
caught in
one of the toughest divisions in all of
football maybe one of the toughest
divisions we've ever seen
the 49ers could be really good the
seahawks could be good
the packers if aaron rodgers shows up
and plays like he did last year could be
really good i think washington is going
to be better than we think
but i still think the buccaneers have
the best chance to emerge if i had to
pick one now i'd say the bucks is the
one seed afc
i got no idea how it's going to go
something i've pointed out before look
at the
look at that conference look at those
divisions the teams that are actual
super bowl contenders
buccaneers not buccaneers wrong
conference bills
patriots ravens browns steelers
titans colts chargers chiefs
and then if rogers would get traded to
the broncos
you add them to the list as well so i
have no idea who the number one seed is
going to be in the afc but i think both
one seeds
clearly have an advantage when it comes
to getting to the super bowl
last year we saw the one seed in
the nfc lose in the nfc championship
game
whereas the one seed in the afc managed
to hold serve in both games but but the
chiefs didn't have it easy against the
browns
they had a little easier against the
bills but they got to the super bowl
and look when we see a super bowl
rematch
it's easy to say that now because those
are the two teams that got to the most
recent super bowl but
this year especially all the work all
the effort all the talent all the
assessment all the study all the
everything the sweat the blood the tears
that go into a season
especially in the afc it's going to come
down to
a lucky break a lucky bounce a bad call
or from the perspective of the team that
benefits from it a good call
it's going to be something screwy that
that i think provides the difference
between the team that emerges as the one
seed and the other teams that get to the
playoffs and i suspect there will be
teams that could have made it to the
super bowl that don't make it to the
playoffs
in the afc
forest edgewood how many teams in the
nfc west make the playoffs this year at
least two
maybe maybe three and you know sims and
i last year were toying with the idea
that
all four could make it and now that
there are three wild cards it's entirely
possible i don't think it's highly
likely but it could happen
i'd say that that at least
two make at least two and then injuries
become a major factor in all of this
we've seen it
already as i've said multiple times now
with cam acres what other injuries are
gonna happen
that changes everything that the injury
angle makes irrelevant months
of talk and assessment and predictions
and it seems like most years there is
that one injury that just causes you to
view a team differently and changes
their fate dramatically and that could
happen to one of these nfc west teams
but if everyone stays healthy
i'd say at least two possibly three
h.s micken what's a successful season
for the patriots this year
i think getting back to the playoffs and
winning a game or two in the postseason
i don't see any reason to think
this team won't be much better than last
year they were seven and nine
even with so little talent relative to
past seasons i think they're going to be
good and i think they will make it to
the playoffs
and when it's single elimination time
they've got the coaching staff
they've got the experience at least
institutionally to figure out how to win
those games and not get freaked out in
the moment like some teams do when they
get to the playoffs for the first time
off topic pft pm posse how's the grill
going been grilling anything
particularly good this summer
i've been trying to go a little
healthier chicken instead of sausage
steak the leaner cuts trying to watch
the cholesterol now that the clock is
ticking toward the
witching hour of 60. grilled some
asparagus last night excellent olive oil
salt and pepper good for you a negative
calorie food
so the grill is a magical device because
even the foods that you otherwise would
not eat if you put them on the grill
they end up tasting pretty damn good
after all so a lot of chicken
this summer and probably some more
chicken coming
tonight all right let's see what else we
got here
last one lee whit what would be a
successful season for the jaguars
that's a great question the jaguars were
1 in 15 last year somehow beat the colts
to start the season and lost 15 in a row
now you've got new coaching staff a head
coach with no nfl experience
trevor lawrence rookie quarterback a new
gm in trent balke although he's been a
gm before
i don't know they're in a tough division
with the titans and the colts
i could see them finishing in third
place i'd say if the jaguars win
at least six games that is a highly
successful season
and that lays the foundation for making
the leap
next year i know every team wants to
come into the year saying we have a
chance to make the playoffs and
in theory every team does but for teams
like the jaguars and jets
breaking in rookie quarterbacks six and
11
should be something that creates real
hope
for next year and that's what the
jaguars have to do i mean
how quickly the jaguars fell apart after
being on the brink of the super bowl
just a few years ago they are
truly building from scratch and i think
if you're a jaguars fan
you just are looking for signs that this
works
that urban meyer belongs in the nfl that
he's not going to burn out quickly like
nick saban did that he's going to be far
closer to jimmy johnson than some of the
other former college coaches who came to
the nfl
under high expectations whether it's
graciano chip kelly or someone else
this year is that test case is there
enough evidence this year to make me
think this is going to work and if there
is maybe it starts working
as soon as 2022. we'll keep working
around the clock at profootballtalk.com
for the rest of the day we'll do this
again tomorrow
thanks as always for some of your time
and we'll talk to you again real soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports